bonjour à tous je vous propose de suivre
cet après-midi l'audition de jean
bernard lévy devant la commission des
affaires économiques du sénat l'ancien
patron de thales a été désigné pour
prendre la tête d'edf
une domination validé dimanche par le
conseil d'administration du géant de
l'électricité
mais avant d'être effective cette
nomination doit être approuvé par les
parlementaires
et c'est ce grand oral devant la
commission des affaires économiques du
sénat que je vous propose de suivre cet
après midi un grand oral suivi d'un vote
des membres de la commission
la nomination de jean bernard lévy doit
ensuite être validé en conseil des
ministres je vous propose donc tout de
suite d'écoutés l'audition de jean
bernard lévy devant la commission des
affaires économiques
nous entendons en application l'article
13 de la constitution monsieur
jean-bernard lévy dont la nomination en
tant que président au directeur général
d'electricité de france est envisagée
par le président de la république
comme vous le savez cette audition et
public
elle est ouverte à la presse à son issue
nous procéderons un vote qui se
déroulera à bulletin secret ce vote ne
sera ouvert qu'aux seuls membres de la
commission des affaires économiques
je rappelle notre parc en application de
l'article 3 de la loi organique du 23
juillet 2010 relative à l'application du
cinquième alinéa de l'article 13 de la
constitution
les délégations de vote ne sont pas
autorisés
la commission affaires économiques de
l'assemblée vous auditionnant à 17
heures c'est après midi donc nous allons
vous libérer en temps et en heure pour
que vous puissiez répondre à cette
convocation nous attendrons la fin de
leur vote pour procéder au dépouillement
qui sera donc simultanées je vous
rappelle enfin que le président de la
république ne pourrait procéder à cette
nomination
si l'addition des votes négatifs de
chaque commission représenter au moins
trois cinquièmes des suffrages exprimés
dans les deux commissions
or je rappelle
monsieur le président que vous avez été
élu vendredi au poste d'administrateur
d'edf par les actionnaires de
l'entreprise réunis en assemblée
générale le conseil d'administration
d'edf validé dimanche qui montrent que
des idées sur le travail le dimanche
commencent à prospérer dans notre pays
votre nomination comme président
directeur général par intérim de la
compagnie d'électricité avec prise de
fonction il médias je rappelle à ce
sujet qu'il y a eu petit malentendu par
rapport aux informations qui étaient
diffusées dans la presse qui laissait
entendre que monsieur lévy était déjà
installé comme président et comme
président d'edf en réalité l'été par
intérim comme seul mandataire social
jusqu'au moment où ils seraient nommés
ça ne peut être que par le conseil des
ministres qui a mis ce point à l'ordre
du jour de sa réunion de demain est donc
sous réserve du vote des deux
commissions sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale
votre nomination sera formalisée par un
décret présidentiel pris après
validation du conseil des ministres il
m'appartient parce que vous n'aurez
évidemment pas la possibilité de le
faire par discrétion de dire quels sont
vos titres
je rappellerai nom très brièvement votre
parcours professionnel qui vous a mis
d'abord à l'école polytechnique et
ensuite à l'école nationale supérieure
des télécommunications devenu télécom
paristech
vous alternez une carrière dans
l'entreprise
justement vous avez été à france télécom
matra espace matra communication la
société de côté en bourse oddo est
depuis décembre 2012 vous êtes le pdg de
thales
vous êtes également passé c'est là où il
ya une alternance par des cabinets
ministériels consécutive directeur de
cabinet du ministre en charge de la fois
des postes télécommunications mais d'une
façon plus générale de l'industrie
cela vous donnera l'occasion je pense de
nous dire en quoi ces allers-retours
entre le monde de l'entreprise et la
cire public ont pu enrichir votre
réflexion sur le rôle de l'état en
matière économique et plus spécifiques
plus spécifiquement ces licences des
secteurs économiques stratégiques
ce que vous le dirait notre parcours
devra nous conforter dans l'idée que
vous êtes le candidat idéal pour occuper
le poste de président directeur général
d'edf
vous nous rappellerait je pense que ce
sera utile pour nos collègues les
chiffres clés de l'entreprise et du
groupe edf
ses atouts aujourd'hui mais également
ses faiblesses et puis nous attendons
aussi que vous nous présentiez votre
stratégie de développement pour cette
grande entreprise que ce soit en france
ou bien sûr à l'international à l'issue
de votre propos liminaire nous sommes
convenus que vous présentiez vous poser
des questions il est normal que vous y
répondiez dans le temps qui sera choisi
par vous je donne ensuite la parole aux
membres de la commission
je demanderai d'ailleurs aux uns et aux
autres de se manifester rapidement pour
qu'on puisse organiser un tour de table
qui puisse éclairer l'ensemble des
membres de la commission sur les vies je
vous donne la parole monsieur le
président ce président lenoir merci
mesdames et messieurs les les sénateurs
je suis d'abord très heureux très
heureux de me présenter devant vous
comme candidat candidat proposé pour la
la présidence d'electricité de france
edf et de pouvoir partager avec vous mes
premières réflexions et ma vision des
enjeux ddf pour les années à venir
préalable je voudrais vous dire que je
suis fier et très honoré d'être
pressenti pour prendre la tête de cette
belle entreprise edf est une entreprise
de service public exceptionnel qui
contribue très largement au bien-être de
nos concitoyens qui contribue à la
compétitivité de la france et qui
contribue au rayonnement de notre pays à
l'étranger
l'edf et r&d symbole de l'excellence
française reconnue dans le monde entier
je mesure le poids des responsabilités
qui sont envisagées la tête d'une
entreprise de 160 mille personnes d'un
chiffre d'affaires de près de 75
milliards d'euros
je voudrais rappeler que les 160 mille
collaborateurs d'edf met chaque jour
leurs compétences et leur dévouement au
service de nos clients nous avons près
de 40 millions de clients monsieur le
président vous avez brièvement rappelé
mon parcours je me sens un ingénieur et
je me sens un industriel
je crois que cela fait du sens pour
entrepris une entreprise comme comme edf
après ma formation j'ai en effet passé
plus de dix ans dans le secteur public
mais j'ai aussi la fibre de l'entreprise
puisque ces vingt dernières années j'ai
rejoint ou dirigé trois grands groupes
trois grands groupes tous français tous
français trois grands groupes engagés
dans la bataille de la compétition
internationale matra viven dit alès cela
me donne une expérience de dirigeant
d'entreprise
après ma formation d'ingénieur qui est
familier du secteur public comme des
grands enjeux internationaux et c'est
avec cette double expérience que je me
présente devant vous aujourd'hui parlons
d'edf edf a à mes yeux toutes les armes
pour réussir au service des français au
service de nos entreprises dans nos
collectivités territoriales et pour
promouvoir la place de la france dans la
bataille de la mondialisation
si vous l'acceptez je porterai pour edf
une grande ambition à la mesure du
parcours d'excellence de l'entreprise à
la mesure de la qualité de ses équipes à
la mesure des formidables enjeux
auquel edf est confronté au 21ème siècle
d'abord edf est une grande entreprise
française de service public la première
mission de dfc de fournir à tous les
français est en permanence une énergie à
un prix qui respecte le pouvoir d'achat
des ménages et qui contribue à la
compétitivité des entreprises
la notion même de droit à l'électricité
montre combien cette mission de service
public qui est fixé par l'état et edf
participe de notre contrat social grâce
au savoir-faire des collaborateurs d'edf
grâce aussi je crois qu'on peut le dire
à la perspicacité de mes prédécesseurs
je voudrais saluer tout particulièrement
président roussely le président gadoneix
et plus dernièrement le président
proglio je voudrais leur rendre hommage
je crois que grâce aux collaborateurs et
à la sagesse des décisions prises
edf permet aujourd'hui à ses clients
français de bénéficier d'une énergie
très largement des cas décarbonés et du
d'énergie à un prix très modéré en
comparaison des prix européens
d'après eurostat les ménages français
payent leur électricité 35% de moins que
nos voisins européens
et lorsque le on se compare à
l'allemagne les ménages français payent
deux fois moins cher qu'en allemagne la
qualité de service qui est fournie par
edf est remarquable y compris dans les
moments critiques
je crois que le sens de l'intérêt
général des équipes d'edf montre
qu'elles servent leurs clients au mieux
et chacun en mémoire l'exceptionnelle
mobilisation des électriciens lors de la
tempête de 1999
je crois que cela a marqué les esprits
durablement je le disais l'électricité
produite par edf et très peu émettrices
de co2 elle est respectueuse de
l'environnement cela permet aussi à
notre pays d'être en pointe dans la
lutte contre le réchauffement
hi matic qui est l'un des grands enjeux
de la communauté des nations
le savoir-faire d'edf est unique au
monde par l'expérience accumulée en
matière de sûreté en particulier en
matière de sûreté nucléaire sujet sur
lequel il n'est pas question de
transiger et dans un environnement
incertain où les événements
géopolitiques peuvent remettre en cause
l'accès d'un pays aux sources d'énergie
edf gdf offre à l'état et à nos
concitoyens la sécurité
d'approvisionnement en électricité edf
est donc le fruit d'une vision
stratégique et d'une excellence
technique qui sont bien française notre
système énergétique et de tout premier
ordre
il entraîne avec lui une filière
industrielle qui excellent dans de
nombreux domaines et en particulier dans
le nucléaire
le volume des investissements d'edf est
d'environ 9 milliards d'euros chaque
année est la référence des f est
essentielle à cette filière d'entreprise
qui comprend de grands groupes comme
areva et alstom mais qui prend qui
comprend aussi plus de 30 mille pme ces
trente mille pme représentent le tiers
des achats du groupe edf edf joue aussi
un rôle essentiel dans le développement
équilibré des territoires ne savent
notamment grâce à sa filiale erdf qui
assure un maillage territorial de
premier ordre grâce aux efforts de ses
35 mille collaborateurs
edf est un employeur de référence c'est
l'une des entreprises préférées des
français
une des entreprises également de choix
pour les ingénieurs qui sortent de nos
écoles edf accueille chaque année 6700
alternant c'est un chiffre très élevé et
edf a décidé récemment de relever son
niveau d'embauchés pour former dans les
meilleures conditions la nouvelle
génération d'opérateurs de techniciens
et d'ingénieurs dans le dos
du nucléaire mais aussi dans la
production d'énergies renouvelables et
dans les technologies de l'efficacité
énergétique
voilà ce qu'on peut dire pour décrire un
petit peu l'entreprise à mes yeux mais
je voudrais profiter de cette audition
pour vous dire quelques mots sur la
transition énergétique sujets dont dams
et messieurs les sénateurs vous
commencez à vous saisir et qui devraient
être abordés par vous même jusque dans
le courant de l'hiver la transition
énergétique
c'est une opportunité essentielle pour
edf
depuis sa création en 1946 edf a
toujours sur l'île relever les défis qui
lui ont été assignés et aujourd'hui avec
la transition énergétique s'ouvre une
nouvelle page edf en sera un acteur
majeur la transition énergétique
tout comme la transition numérique qui
impactent directement nos activités et
nos métiers bien la transition
énergétique est une opportunité
enthousiasmante pour innover pour
développer de nouveaux savoir faire de
nouveaux produits de nouveaux services
et je suis sûr qu edf sera remplir cette
mission
comme les précédentes en quelques mots
dans le cadre de la transition
énergétique
mon projet serait d'abord que des f
puisse être un acteur important des
nouveaux services énergétiques
le marché des services énergétiques est
un marché en croissance on estime la
croissance moyenne annuelle en europe
entre 5 et 10 % notamment grâce à dalkia
une acquisition récente du groupe edf
edf pourra être présent sur l'ensemble
de la chaîne de valeur cela inclut la
rénovation des logements
cela inclut une activité de conseil et
de présence auprès des collectivités
comme des clients industriels et cela
inclut bien sûr la production
décentralisée
il s'agit aussi pour edf de développer
le domaine des énergies renouvelables
aujourd'hui edf énergies nouvelles
permet déjà au groupe edf de se situer
parmi les 10 leaders mondiaux dans les
énergies renouvelables
cette position s'appuie sur un socle
historique qui est le formidable parc
hydraulique que des f a construit au au
fil du 20e siècle
cette position est maintenant relayée
par les investissements qui sont faits
dont le solaire et dans le
photovoltaïque la transition énergétique
c'est aussi l'opportunité pour edf de
renouveler et d'optimiser son parc
nucléaire est au premier plan des
priorités d'edf doit bien sûr figure et
la réussite du chantier de flamanville
le p r qui doit être mise en service en
nous avons aussi devons-nous le
lancement d'un programme très important
le programme dit de grand carénage qui
permettra d'allonger la durée de vie des
centrales nucléaires qui ont été
construites du milieu des années 70 au
milieu des années 90 ce programme de
grand carénage entraînera des bénéfices
économiques majeurs pour notre pays pour
l'activité économique l'activité
industrielle tout en respectant bien
entendu les prescriptions de l'autorité
de sûreté nucléaire
la transition énergétique répond aussi à
une contrainte environnementale et à des
aspirations sociétal l'edf se doit donc
d'être au rendez-vous de la transition
énergétique
c'est une opportunité pour le
développement des activités d'edf et
pour la pérennité du service public
c'est non seulement une exigence
environnementale mais aussi un impératif
social et je pense en particulier au
traitement de la précarité énergétique
la transition énergétique est enfin un
levier pour fonder une nouvelle
croissance nouvelle croissance fondée
sur la compétitivité de la filière
énergétique au service des entreprises
et au service de l'emploi
je voudrais vous parler des grands
enjeux du groupe edf et je les ai
classés en cinq catégories qui
rappellent l'ampleur des mutations qui
sont devant nous le premier enjeu à mes
yeux c'est d'assainir d'améliorer la
situation économique du groupe edf
nous constatons aujourd'hui des retards
préoccupant sur les trajectoires réel
des tarifs par rapport aux trajectoires
qui avait pourtant été convenu avec
l'état retard préoccupant sur les tarifs
de détail
le tarif régulé de vente mais aussi sur
les tarifs de gros comme la reine ces
écarts conduisent edf à augmenter sans
cesse sa dette
comme vous le savez sans doute mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
chaque année c'est l'endettement qui
permet de payer le dividende à mes yeux
un rééquilibrage tarifaire s'impose
ce rééquilibrage tarifaire passe aussi
par une stabilisation ou en tout cas une
mise sous contrôle de la cspe dont la
croissance rapide est un souci je crois
que c'est seulement sous cette condition
d'un rééquilibrage de son compte
d'exploitation en france qu edf pourra
rester l'un des tout premiers
énergéticiens mondiaux je reconnais que
c'est un objectif difficile
il me semble que c'est d'un objectif
primordial second enjeu les produits et
la conduite des projets en particulier
dans le domaine nucléaire
l'ensemble de ces sujets seront pour moi
dès mon arrivée si vous le voulez bien
une priorité essentielle avec de
nombreux thèmes le sujet de l'épée air
de flamanville 3 dont nous savons que
malheureusement les délais dérivés qu'il
s'agit de livrer dès que possible en
respectant également les devis le sujet
d'hinckley poynt très important pour le
succès de zdf
rhji au royaume uni mais aussi très
important dans le cadre du partenariat
avec la chine
nos partenaires chinois chez edf sont un
atout dans le développement
international d'edf depuis 30 ans le
sujet de la relation sur les produits et
les projets avec areva philippe varin
qui est pressenti pour la présidence
d'areva et moi même nous aurions donc
quelques dans quelques semaines à nous
pencher de façon très étroite sur
l'efficacité de ce partenariat et voir
comment l'améliorer améliorer le
partenariat entre edf et areva au
bénéfice de nos clients et au bénéfice
de la collectivité nationale
encore un sujet dans l'est sur les
produits le sujet de l'optimisation du
coût des épées des ep r nous en sommes
encore au prototype
comment faire baisser le coût des ep air
suivant et enfin nous aurons chez edf
des décisions à prendre dans la
catégorie des centrales dites de moyenne
puissance ça fait tout de même 1000
mégawatts sur lesquels il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui une offre claire troisième
catégorie d'enjeux sur les activités
aval
je suis en parlais tout à l'heure dans
le cadre de la transition énergétique
edf doit jouer tout son rôle dans la
production décentralisée dans le domaine
des énergies renouvelables dans des
relations étroites et de confiance avec
les collectivités territoriales dans les
services énergétiques
la révolution numérique aura également
un impact fort sur edf pour optimiser
l'efficacité énergétique et de ce point
de vue le compteur linky est une
première application premières
applications prometteuses
probablement même excellente 4e en jeu
les dossiers internationaux
edf dispose de positions importantes en
europe grande bretagne italie belgique
pologne qu'il s'agit de conforter et au
delà me semble nécessaire qu edf puisse
déployer une politique internationale
qui soit bien centré sur ses objectifs
stratégiques
en particulier dans des pays comme la
chine si vous le voulez bien il me
reviendra de préciser ses objectifs est
de focaliser les efforts d'edf sur
quelques pays réellement stratégique
enfin cinquième en jeu qui n'est pas le
moindre
la gestion des déchets à longue durée de
vie
6 géo le projet cigéo est un projet
économique et technologique important
sur bien des plans et notamment parce
qu'il s'agit d'un legs aux générations
futures
il me semble nécessaire de trouver
rapidement la voie d'un consensus entre
edf et l'andra l' agence de gestion des
déchets radioactifs de façon qu'on
puisse développer en france une filière
du démantèlement et du traitement des
déchets qui aujourd'hui n'existe pas à
réellement ni en france ni ailleurs dans
le monde qui est pourtant une nécessité
pour les différents pays équipés de
réacteurs nucléaires
je voudrais conclure cette présentation
liminaire en évoquant devant vous mon
projet managériale pour edf
j'en suis convaincu
l'avenir du monde dépend pour beaucoup
du secteur de l'énergie edf a de
multiples potentiel de développement en
france et à l'international
les femmes et des hommes d'edf ont les
talents les compétences aussi
l'engagement la passion du service
public le sens du collectif
ce sont des forces sur lesquelles
l'entreprise pourra construire son
avenir à nous de savoir les mobiliser au
service d'une aventure exaltante pour
que l'entreprise et ses collaborateurs
continuent à innover à entreprendre à
aller toujours plus loin
à mes yeux edf grand énergéticien
mondial peut être le premier et des
rejets titien mondiale
edf doit se doter d'un projet à moyen
terme ambitieux projet à moyen terme qui
permet de mobiliser tous les talents de
l'entreprise edf doit tenir compte d'un
nouvel environnement exigeant mais
stimulant marquée par la loi de
transition énergétique mais aussi le
paquet européen climat énergie et les
perspectives des résultats de la
conférence de paris en fin d'année 2015
coop 21 pour rassembler edf autour d'une
stratégie partagée
je compte engager un projet de
transformation ce projet impliquera un
effort de transparence un effort de
prospective notamment à travers les
programmations pluriannuelles de
l'énergie telles qu'elles sont prévues
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la loi de
transition énergétique dans ce projet
partagé le dialogue social aura toute sa
place afin de mobiliser les énergies
dont le groupe
je voudrais aussi vous dire que si vous
acceptez ma candidature je veillerai à
la transparence
cette transparence est due aux
actionnaires en particulier à l'état
elle est également due à la
représentation nationale
et si vous voulez bien vite et je serais
heureux de me rendre régulièrement
devant lui pour conclure je voudrais
dire que edf est le fruit d'une aventure
collective qui a été engagé il ya
maintenant plus de 60 ans les femmes et
les hommes qui ont fait le succès de df
qui ont fait l'histoire plus anciennes
mais aussi l'histoire contemporaine
d'edf
ils sont fiers à juste titre des succès
du service public les technologies et
savoir-faire développé en france grâce à
edf nous sont enviées dans le monde
entier justifie l'attachement
extraordinaire des collaborateurs à leur
entreprise
il me reviendra si vous l'approuvez de
relever avec eux
tous ces nouveaux défis je vous remercie
de votre attention et je suis maintenant
avec un grand plaisir prêt à répondre à
vos questions
merci monsieur président pour cette
présentation j'ai d'ores et déjà
plusieurs intervenants qui se sont
inscrits je donne de suite la parole à
ladislas poniatowski merci monsieur le
président oui serait trop long trop long
je voudrais je vous posais 4,4 question
la première gdf est une entreprise
endettée
très endettée et pourtant elle va devoir
faire face à des investissements
importants que ce soit je parle du
domaine nucléaire
que ce soit tous les travaux que vous
allez devoir réaliser d'investissements
pour ce que j'appelle le post fukushima
mais en même temps d'autres travaux très
importants pour la prolongation de durée
de vie des centrales
au fur et à mesure que l'autorité sûreté
nucléaire va on vous autorisé à
prolonger la durée de vos centrales vous
aurez on sait bien quelque part entre
300 et 600 millions d'investissements à
faire à réacteurs vous avez besoin
d'argent
dans le texte de loi sur la formation
c'est est-ce qu'elle est votre point de
vue sur une éventuelle ouverture non pas
du capital d'edf
mais l'ouverture d'un éventuel capital
par centrale dans le texte de loi sur la
transition énergétique
on a trouvé une solution pour
l'hydraulique afin de pas ne pas brader
notre hydraulique et que l'étranger
puissent mettre la main sur nos
centrales hydrauliques
on a inventé des scènes dans lequel il
pourrait y avoir un partage
d'investissement public privé ce qui
vous permettra peut-être à vous et df de
garder un grand nombre de vos centrales
hydrauliques en ouvrant quand même une
partie de la propriété de ce central à
d'autres collectivités locales ou tiers
est ce que pour les centrales nucléaires
ça ne serait pas possible j'ai toujours
défendu ce ce point de vue là il ya déjà
cinq centrales françaises qui
n'appartiennent pas que à aider f
dont une partie de la propriété est à
d'autres jusqu'à 25% pour l'une d'entre
elles qui appartiennent à des belges qui
appartiennent à des réseaux et des
suisses donc à des sociétés étrangères
est ce que ce n'est pas une manière de
résoudre ce problème d'investissement
deuxième question votre filiale erdf
elle gagne bien sa vie elle gagne bien
sa vie et pourtant les réseaux français
de distribution sont anciens et aux
besoins d'investissement et le problème
de rdf c'est que pendant quatre ans il y
à un effort qui a été fait pour rendre
investir fortement sur tout le réseau
erdf globalement basse tension sur
l'ensemble du territoire
or edf a repris depuis deux ans ses
mauvaises habitudes qu'elle a pratiqué
pendant dix ans c'est à dire en tant qu
actionnaire unique vous prélevez
beaucoup des résultats des rdf
je pense que c'est une erreur le réseau
n'est pas en bon état
il est temps que l'état sait qu'il est
vieux il faut progressivement le
remplacer il faut repartir dans une
phase d'investissement j'aimerais avoir
votre point de vue là-dessus troisième
question monsieur le président vous avez
fait allusion à le p r bon
malheureusement on était a été annoncé
il ya dix jours le retard encore du
démarrage de le père de flamanville à
en termes d'image de marque de la france
acteur important du nucléaire et
vendeurs de centrales à l'étranger
c'est pas bon je vous ai entendu vous
avez dit qu'il fallait je dirais faire
des économies en termes de coûts c'est
elle c'est le produit le prototype pour
les autres à venir il faut faire des
économies ou faire des recherches
j'aurais aimé en savoir un tout petit
peu plus et dernière question monsieur
le président je vous ai bien entendu
mais c'est malheureusement c'est pas
vous qui décidez vous avez dit et c'est
vrai c'est une charge que vous supporter
financièrement parlant
la solution la connaît c'est de vous
autoriser à augmenter les prix de
l'électricité afin de que vous puissiez
vous payez sur ce qui vous est dû si
vous qui faites la trésorerie
de l'état français actuellement
malheureusement la loi sur la transition
énergétique est déjà passé devant
l'assemblée nationale
ça vient chez nous nos collègues députés
ont fait preuve de beaucoup
d'imagination et très souvent la
solution pour payer des idées des
projets nouveaux
par qui ou par quoi c'est ont payé ses
idées nouvelles avaient en charge le
baudet cspe
donc on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
mais monsieur le président je voulais
simplement votre avis là dessus mais
c'est pas vous qui pouvez décider
ce sont là creux et le gouvernement
merci merci mon cher collègue merci pour
la concision contribution au service
public de l'électricité c'est une ligne
qui apparaît sur toute facture
d'électricité payé par un consommateur
et c'est sur cette ligne là que pèse 1,5
de charges alors dont le renouvelable
la péréquation tarifaire la continuité
territoriale les départements et
territoires d'outre-mer
le tarif social est également celle à
contribution oui pardon aux charges du
médiateur national de l'énergie
ces mineurs j'en conviens mais la liste
est exhaustive
alors la parole et à yannick vaugrenard
et ensuite doré la parole à daniel
dubois
merci monsieur le président pardonnez
moi d'abord pour
comme mon retard au début de la réunion
mais le congrès des maires nous impose
certaines obligations est difficile
d'avoir le don d'ubiquité
quelques éléments de deux spots de
satisfaction et d'autres plutôt de
préoccupation ou d'inquiétude éléments
satisfaction d'abord parce qu
incontestablement edf est une très
grande entreprise nationale et même
d'envergure internationale vous l'avez
souligné
autre élément de satisfaction pour notre
pays le fait d'avoir développé justement
l'énergie nucléaire au moment où il
fallait le faire nous a permis une
indépendance énergétique majeur avec une
production d'électricité à 75 %
d'origine nucléaire
aujourd'hui edf a donc échappé à la
crise qui ébranle ses concurrents qui
sont beaucoup plus dépendant des
énergies fossiles mais ça ne concerne
pas seulement la france
aujourd'hui l'allemagne de par le choix
rapide voire précipitée qui a fait
devient extrêmement dépendant des
importations qui viennent de russie
par conséquent la question qui peut se
poser avec des f
au-delà de l'aspect national n'est-il
pas aussi d'appréhender l'indépendance
énergétique de notre continent pour des
questions géopolitiques qui ne sont
également pas masse dépend de
l'approvisionnement énergétique
uniquement de l'est ou du sud peut poser
demain des problèmes politiques qui me
semble qui me semblent majeur quelles
différences voyez vous entre le
souhaitable
compte tenu du réchauffement du
réchauffement climatique entre le fait
de passer de 75% à 50% d'énergie
nucléaire en relativement peu de temps
selon vous entre ce souhaitable et le
possible
quelle différence vous y voyez
objectivement flamanville lepers est
évoquée tout de suite
le nom âge achèvement de le p r selon
vous va-t-il aller jusqu'en 2017 ou
éventuellement encore un peu plus et
quelle différence entre le coût
prévisible
aujourd'hui et le coût prévisionnel
quelques il était envisagé voici voici
quelques temps allonger la durée de vie
des centrales
le probablement inévitable selon vous
est ce que pour autant les conditions de
sécurité sont optimums ou est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir éventuellement un doute un
dément de indépendamment du cou qui est
évoqué il semble aujourd'hui nécessaire
compte tenu de la difficulté rencontrée
par areva de resserrer les liens entre
edf et areva
quel intérêt pour edf
quels risques pour edf également
enfin s'agissant des énergies
renouvelables quelle est la stratégie de
recherche aujourd'hui menée par par edf
on sait que la difficulté essentielle
c'est le stockage des énergies notamment
des énergies éoliennes est ce que vous
avez le sentiment qu'on peut avancer en
termes de recherche appliquée
fondamental dans ce domaine là où est ce
qu'on arrive et ce que nous sommes
arrivés un butoir qui est difficile à
franchir
et enfin l'énergie hydrolienne a le
mérite de se renouveler en permanence
est-ce que vous pensez que les
recherches dans ce domaine là qu'ils ont
beaucoup avancé notamment son plan la
recherche fondamentale peut très
rapidement devenir très positive en
termes de recherche de recherche
impliqués merci mon cher collègue je
donne maintenant la parole à daniel
dubois et ensuite à gérard césar
merci président comme j'ai été cité jeu
posé une seule question donc au
président il nous a dit finalement on a
un retard sur les sur les tarifs et les
dividendes on les paye géré en faisant
des emprunts jeu j'aimerais savoir c'est
quelle recette il a pour faire admettre
aux gouvernements verrez que les tarifs
sont tout la réalité et qu'il faut les
augmenter
tout en sachant
résidents que on a un avantage
concurrentiel énorme au niveau de
l'industrie
oui puisqu'on a un prix effectivement
airs et de l'énergie aie qui nous donne
un avantage concurrentiel indéniable
aujourd'hui
merci mon cher connais je dois mettre
dans la parole à gérard césar et ensuite
à philippe leroy oui mais remercie
monsieur le président futur président
directeur général d'edf et je voulais
vous dire que je me réjouis des
relations que nous avons sur le terrain
avec donc en tant que l'association des
maires avec les services d'edf mais
aussi ceux de erdf votre filiale la
question que je voulais opposé ça
concerne les compteurs linky vous avez
fait allusion tout à l'heure c'est le
conteur dirigeants d'après ce qu'on nous
dit s'il est intelligent se comptèrent
je souhaite que ce soit pas le milieu
urbain uniquement qui ce qu'ils y soient
donc attendu fourniture aux deux
scooters mais que le milieu rural aussi
soir concernés par la fourniture ses
comptes à de ce conte est intelligent
deuxième question que je voulais opposé
que pensez vous de la mise en place des
correspondants tempête vous avez fait
allusion à tempête 99 nous avons nous en
gironde une expérience malheureuse
puisqu'elle est beaucoup de pain et
beaucoup de dégâts au niveau des lignes
électriques et nous avons mis en place à
la suite cela des correspondants tempête
ça vire sont des élus municipaux qui
s'en charge et d'avoir de subir de
suivre pardon peut subir suivre une
formation est ensuite bien sûr guider
les équipes qui arrivent du nord de la
france ou d'italie où ayew d'ailleurs
d'allemagne sur le terrain parce que il
ya une perte considérable de temps si
ces équipes qui viennent de l'étranger
ou de du nord de la france ne peuvent
pas être guidé par les correspondants
tempête ça c'est une formation que nous
faisons régulièrement avec les services
edf ça marche très très bien le gagner
question que je me posais l'alsace
potasse qui a fait état et yannick
vaugrenard
c'est par rapport aux flamands
flamanville 3 mais aussi jouer savoir où
nous en sommes parce que nous avons
visités à l'époque donc la construction
de d'une centrale nucléaire
bulgari si je me souviens bien et je
voulais savoir où j'en étais et parce
qu'il y avait des surcoûts importants
parce que l'énorme charge changer sans
arrêt et l'autorité de surêté nucléaire
était toujours en train de rajouter une
couche au niveau donc en ce qui concerne
les références et le fonctionnement de
la centrale
voilà monsieur le président directeur
futur les questions que je voulais
opposé merci mon cher collègue donne la
parole à philippe roy et ensuite à
daniel grémillet très très rapidement
tout a été déjà balayé mais simplement
sur les recettes de l'est l'essentiel
des recettes vient de la vente
d'électricité ou du moins en france
quels sont les quelles sont les
évolutions législatives que vous verriez
que pour améliorer vos performances en
titre des recettes dans la mesure où le
nos prix sont déjà inférieurs au marché
européen derrière ça il ya la
possibilité d'investir d'investir
ladislas a fait tout à leur mention
d'appels à des intervenants extérieurs
pour trouver un peu d'argent mais c'est
quand même au niveau des recettes que on
trouvera l'essentiel est dans les
investissements
vous nous avez parlé des grand carénage
mais grand carénage
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important pour l'économie les économies
locales
l'ours qui a nécessité de carénage il y
a un énorme chiffre d'affaires c'est de
l'ordre du milliard d'euros et même au
delà pour les grosses centrales et ça
fait travailler énormément d'entreprises
pendant quelques années sur un site et
entre la ja un moyen de reprise et de
relance de l'économie
quelle est la position vous avez dans
les différentes priorités que vous que
vous vous donnez qu'est la priorité vous
donner à cette notion de carénage enfin
on sait qu'au niveau d'un de la
recherche sur les réseaux intelligents
les réseaux qui sont tous interconnectés
au plan européen
quelle est l'action edf peut
entreprendre ou prendre des initiatives
notamment sur le stockage de
l'électricité qui devient une nécessité
avec la diversification des sources
d'énergie
quelle est la priorité aussi vous donner
vous vous donnez en matière de recherche
ste stockage de l'électricité
merci vous chers collègues je donne la
parole à daniel grille et ensuite à
franck montaugé
oui merci beaucoup président d'abord
c'est très intéressant de connaître déjà
l'ambition que vous avez pour le groupe
edf
je dis ça parce que on est dans un pays
où l'industrie bénéficie largement d'un
prix très concurrentiels au niveau de
l'énergie qui compense quelque part en
matière de compétitivité
les surcoûts nous pour avoir notamment
par rapport au système social et
la rénumération donc ma question de sur
cet aspect comment effectivement faire
que on garde de cet avantage
concurrentiel industrielle sachant qu'on
a besoin de reconquérir la partie
industrielle productive dans notre pays
donc où l'énergie aura une place
stratégique du manière compétitive par
rapport à cette précarité vis-à-vis des
ménages qui ne faut pas non plus
négliger sur la précarité énergétique
des ménages sur cette capacité et ses
contradictions
une autre question c'est la séparation
edf et erdf et est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas
dans la même situation que la sncf rff
sur des stratégies communes partagées
en terme d'efficacité dire qu'on voit
bien les limites étant élu dans une
région ou bien les limites qu'on des
discussions qu'on peut avoir entre erdf
et entre erdf entre la sncf et rff est
quelque part sur les lignes on ça
m'intéresse beaucoup de connaître votre
point de vue là et puis dernier point
comment dans cette ambition que vous
avez imaginé faire partager les grands
investissements nécessaires à edf pour
le futur aujourd'hui on est dans une
acceptation de plus en plus difficile y
compris des énergies renouvelables dans
notre société on veut faire des parcs
éoliens c'est compliqué on faire des
retenues d'eau c'est très compliqué on
veut aller plus loin dans le nucléaire
c'est aussi très compliqué donc comment
et pourtant c'est stratégique
comment être plus efficace entre les
idées qu'on peut avoir la compétitivité
nécessaires à l'acceptation par rapport
aux citoyens merci mon cher collègue je
donne la parole à franck montaugé
ensuite dominique estrosi
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur lévi votre exposé je voudrais
revenir sur le projet managériale que
vous avez évoquées vous avez souligné
vous avez eu raison et l'expérience la
compétence la passion le sens du
collectif des personnels d'edf
vous en avez a appelé à la nécessité
d'élaborer un projet social et j'aurai
deux questions comment ce projet social
envisagez vous de le construire
collectivement pour que justement les
points positifs que vous avez souligné
souligner quant à l'engagement des
personnels soit demeure demeure dans la
durée et d'autre part
vous avez vous avez souligné
l'ancienneté de l'entreprise de edf et
effectivement elle a presque soixante
dix ans il ya soixante dix ans c'était
un gain de 6 a été votée par le
parlement français
un statut celui des industries
électriques et gazières et je voudrais
savoir si vous envisagez que ce statut
demeure de droit commun j'ai envie de
dire par rapport aux personnels qui
pourraient être embauchés dans l'avenir
ou si ce statut est appelé par rapport
aux évolutions que vous souhaitez
peut-être nécessiter si ce statut et est
appelée à devenir une exception c'est à
dire que le recrutement se fasse sous
sous sous d'autres formes statutaire que
que celui du des statuts de 1946 merci
pour vos réponses
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
dominique estrosi
oui juste deux questions j'aurais
revenir sur les relations est nécessaire
entre areva et edf
qu'en est-il de l'accord de coopération
sur la conception et la
commercialisation des nouveaux réacteurs
notamment pour pouvoir rationaliser les
missions d'ingénierie entre les deux
groupes
ensuite comment vous envisagez de voir
qu'il y ait plus de liant davantage de
liens entre les deux conseils
d'administration celui d'edf et celui
d'areva
et puis une autre question qui est
beaucoup plus général et qui et comment
arriver à concilier la création d'un
marché européen de l'énergie avec une
volonté affichée le développement
durable merci match et recollait je
m'ajoute à la liste des intervenants
pour poser quelques questions qui ont
déjà été effleurée d'ailleurs par un
savon de mes collègues a tout d'abord
par rapport à l'objectif qui figure dans
le projet de loi sur la transition
énergétique c'est 50% nucléaire d'ici à
2025 question claire et nette
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
réalisable deuxièmement on n'a pas parlé
de fessenheim il y encore un an et
quelques mois un ministre en charge de
l'écologie mais n'est plus en charge
ce département ministériel affirmé je
fermerai fessenheim avant 2016 avant fin
2016 bon il été dit à l'époque que
l'entreprise edf avait engagé une
procédure pour se conformer à la volonté
d'actionnaires pense qu il ne vous est
pas possible de rôder vous dire où on en
est puisque vous avez à prendre vos
fonctions au moment où nous parlons
mais est-ce que d'ores et déjà vous avez
eu l'occasion d'avoir des précisions sur
sur ce point ensuite une question qui
était à plusieurs reprises évoqué la
question du prix la question du coût est
ce que vous êtes en mesure d'ores et
déjà d'avoir une idée sur ce que coûte
l'électricité notamment d'origine
nucléaire il y a eu plusieurs commission
denquête une première au sénat une
ensuite à l'assemblée nationale pour
essayer d'approcher ce que peut coûter
l'électricité sortie d'une centrale
nucléaire
la question n'est pas neutre puisque
dans la loi nome vous avez fameuses
arènes qui est donc le tarif nucléaire
vendue aux concurrents d'edf aujourd'hui
42 euros est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment qui était celui de votre
prédécesseur françois henri proglio qui
estimé que c'était brad et que ça ne
correspondait pas du tout une réalité
que c'était beaucoup plus cher est du
reste un certain nombre de parties
prenantes dans le monde politique en
tout cas estimé que le mégawatt
nucléaire était plutôt près de 56 euros
60 euros mais on a aussi une ruse
référence ses contrats avec la grande
bretagne
on est à plus de 100 euros alors c'est
important pour une raison simple c'est
que les directives européennes nous
oblige à ce que le prix couvre les coûts
et donc à partir du moment où on
commence à approcher un chiffre qui
corresponde à une réalité il y a une
conséquence qui évidemment pas la vôtre
qui est celle de la creuse la commission
de régulation de l'énergie qui est
d'avoir des tarifs je parle évidemment
des tarifs qui soit à la hauteur des
coûts quand il est l'heure les prix
doivent couvrir les coûts je me reprends
ses les tarifs régulés fixé par
administration qui doivent couvrir les
coûts dont c'est une question c'est une
question importante qui ne dépend pas
que du groupe edf dit son président mais
sur lequel vous serez amené à vous
prononcer alors concernant le compteur
linky monsieur le président je vous
invite évidemment à de grandes
précautions oratoires car vous avez dans
cette salle les deux parlementaires qui
ont écrit les auteurs d'un rapport
ladislas poniatowski et votre serviteur
à l'époque j'étais député donc ladislas
était le sénateur co-auteur de ce
rapport donnant d'ailleurs le feu vert
l'époque c'était en 2011 donnant le feu
vert au gouvernement pour ce qui
concerne le déploiement qui a été depuis
décidé par l'actuel gouvernement du
compteur linky mais ça nous paraît un
outil essentiel si on veut
je dirais réguler l'offre la demande
en attendant qu'on puisse vraiment
stocker l'électricité ce qui un jour se
fera lui qui pour l'instant apparaît
difficile enfin dernière dernière
question est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que l'état peut être amené
dans un avenir relativement proche a à
faire les poches d'edf et à vendre des
actions pour tout simplement augmenter
ses recettes ou en tout cas les
optimiser bien on peut on peut poser les
questions qu'on veut est en fait celui
qui est appelé à répondre répond à veut
retenir sur le président nous vous
écoutons bien mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs merci de vos très nombreuses
questions qui montrent combien vous vous
maîtrisez ces sujets que je découvre
depuis peu de temps et sur lequel je
vais vous donner les réponses que que je
suis en mesure de vous donner à ce stade
puisque je n'ai pas pris mes fonctions
que ma science est récente et que
j'aurai certainement à revenir devant
vous pour aborder de façon reçu presque
vous permettez justement d'apporter de
pression important c'est que nous vous
écoutons aurait dû le dire le dire dès
l'entrée de la réunion
nous écoutons en tant que candidat au
poste de président mais nous écouterons
à nouveau si vous êtes géraud nommé
après le conseil des ministres de demain
nous écouterons à nouveau alors sans
doute en janvier dans le cadre des
travaux que nous menons sur la loi
transition énergétique
d'ailleurs merci beaucoup et en effet
prenons prenons le principe de ceux de
ce rendez vous qui me permettra je
l'espère d'être plus plus au fait de
certains des sujets mais je voudrais
quand même vous donner des réponses
aussi précise que possible sur les
sujets multiples que vous avez abordé
peut-être en essayant de l'est de les
regrouper
je crois que le
quand je parlais des enjeux et je
parlais au jeu de l'ensemble des
équilibres économiques très grand nombre
de vos de vos interventions commencer
par celle du monsieur poniatowski et
bien d'autres après lui tournent autour
de la faisabilité pour edf dans
l'équation économique qui est la sienne
des missions qui lui sont confiées elles
sont elles faisable conditions dans les
conditions économiques actuelles
sachant qu'il y a bien sûr de la part de
tout gouvernement je crois qu'on peut le
dire des réticences à augmenter les
tarifs
même si les calculs en montre la
nécessité à certains moments eh bien on
inscrit des provisions au bilan ou bien
on retarde un certain nombre de
décisions et est ce que tout cela ne
m'est pas edf dans une dans une
situation délicate géant vous donne
envie de vous répondre oui c'est bien
mon analyse est ce stade la situation
pour edf est difficile si il n'y a pas
des augmentations de tarifs qui
permettent d'engager les investissements
qui sont nécessaires nous aurons à faire
des choix
vous avez souligné les choix qui sont à
faire pour la rénovation des réseaux de
distribution chez erdf et vous avez les
uns et les autres souligné le
renouvellement du parc de centrales à
travers ce qu'on appelle le grand
carénage qui je crois fait l'objet d'un
consensus
je crois que les gens sont d'accord pour
dire que la meilleure solution pour le
parc nucléaire actuel et je réponds là
aussi à l'une et des interrogations que
vous aviez la meilleure solution est
bien dans le respect des prescriptions
de l'autorité de sûreté est en
accroissement en accroissant dans le
cadre des dispositions dites post
fukushima le niveau de sûreté qui est en
vigueur sur le partage le parc actuel
pour l'amener à un niveau proche
similaires ou comparables à ce qu'on
trouvera dans les dents les op r le
problème se pose bien don de faire ce
grand carénage qui est certainement sur
le plan économique
ce que ce soit au niveau des prix d'edf
ou au niveau de l'activité économique
sur le territoire puisque ces
investissements sont très élevés et que
une bonne partie est centralisée auprès
des fournisseurs industriels mais une
grande partie aussi est faite localement
dans les centres de production tout ceci
nous conduit t-il oui ou non à un
faisabilité d'or cet équilibre
économique
eh bien je dirais la loi de transition
énergétique va nous permettre de dégager
des trajectoires en matière de
programmation la loi de transition
énergétique peut être couplé avec la
transparence que je voudrais renforcer
dans la capacité d'edf à montrer ses
différents scénarios ces différentes
alternatives en matière d'investissement
je crois que ceci devrait faciliter la
nécessaire je dirais même
l'indispensable remontée du niveau des
tarifs
on a parlé aussi beaucoup d'entre vous
des avantages compétitifs d'edf
notamment vis-à-vis des industries je
voudrais rappeler que lorsque je citais
les comparisons tarifaire avec
l'allemagne la différence est très forte
entre ce que payent les ménages
allemands est ce que payent les ménages
français les ménages allemands prennent
beaucoup plus que le ménage français par
contre les industriels allemands payent
de ce que je comprends à peu près la
même chose que les industriels français
et donc le transfert qui se fait dé
facto entre les différentes catégories
d'utilisateurs montre bien où s'est
logée ou a été décidé la priorité en
matière de compétitivité
comment les grilles tarifaires en
réalité dans chez notre grand voisin
favorise la compétitivité de l'industrie
et l'activité économique
alors qu'en france finalement partage
différents a été fait l'électricité
globalement et moins cher mais c'est ce
sont les ménages qui en profitent
davantage donc je pense qu'à un moment
donné
et ceci était clair dans les questions
qui ont été qui ont été posées il faudra
quand même réfléchir en toute
transparence et au bon rythme à ce qu'il
faudra faire en matière en matière de
hausse des tarifs et de suivi des
analyses de coûts qui ont été faites
nous en part nié monsieur le président
qui ont été faites ont été validés par
la commission de régulation de l'énergie
qui évidemment joue un rôle central et
je crois très apprécié pour suivre ces
dossiers et pour fixer les coûts les
prix et donner des indications dont bien
sûr l'entreprise edf aimerait qu'elle
soit plus rapidement et plus strictement
suivi par les décideurs les décideurs
politiques
ces investissements bien vous avez
évoqué différentes options comment
l'entreprise pourrait-elle
trouver des amodiations des
accommodements par rapport à sa
structure actuelle est en effet le
sénateur poniatowski le disait président
le noir le disait aussi il n'y a t'il
pas des moyens financiers qui
permettraient de de compenser cette
équation économique difficile dans
laquelle et edf pour ma part il me
semble qu'au temps il a été logique à un
certain moment que des partenaires
étrangers des électriciens étrangers
viennent partager des investissements à
quelques quelques centrales notamment à
la frontière nord-est du pays mais pas
seulement c'était le cas historiquement
aussi de moyens de production dans la
vallée du rhône quelques moyens de
production sont partagés avec des
électriciens partenaires étrangers mais
en échange d'un droit d'enlèvement n'est
ce pas et dans la mesure où edf a besoin
de cette capacité ce n'est pas cette
solution qui va permettre de maintenir
les capacités d'edf en trouvant un
financement alternatif et pour ma part
je puis vous dire que je ne serai pas
favorable à ce que des intérêts
financiers qui vont chercher à optimiser
le profit sur une partie bien spécifique
du parc
peut-être la partie qu'on nous envie le
plus en matière de compétitivité qui est
notre parc nucléaire
je ne serai pas favorable à ce que des
intérêts financiers veut se substituer
au financement exclusif par edf qui me
paraît le plus apte sous le contrôle des
pouvoirs publics sous le contrôle de
l'état de la représentation nationale
l'ensemble des parties prenantes le plus
apte à faire les meilleurs arbitrage
collectif entre les différentes formes
d'énergie et donc autant on peut sur tel
ou tel aspect créer des partenariats
avec des électriciens étrangers autant
je préfèrerais largement que des f reste
maître complètement de l'avenir de son
cette partie du parc qui lui sert
directement en termes de fourniture
électrique et qu'il n'y ait pas de
mélange entre des objectifs nationaux
les objectifs collectifs en matière
d'énergie
et des objectifs plus ponctuels plus
limité peut-être plus financier sur tel
ou tel aspect de notre parc de
production et je pense ainsi répondre à
un certain nombre d des sujets qui ont
été abordés sur l'aspect sur différents
aspects on a parlé de le p r on a parlé
de la relation avec arriva madame
estrosi notamment à parler de certains
aspects plus ponctuelles dans les
relations
je souhaite sincèrement que la période
qui je l'espère va démarrer soit une
période de coopération sincère entre
areva et edf l'état a manifesté son
intention que des administrateurs soit
comme un monsieur varin qui a été élu
administrateur vendredi est pressenti
pour prendre la présidence d'areva
d'autres personnes qui sont à la qui ont
des responsabilités éminentes au sein de
l'état si je suis bien informé pourrait
également jouer un rôle majeur en étant
présent dans les dents les deux conseils
je crois qu'il s'agit de symboliser le
fait qu'on tourne la page sur une
période où je dirais d'hostilité
peut-être le mot n'est pas trop fort
entre deux grandes entreprises
françaises qui n'avaient pas de raison
de montrer de l'hostilité l'une envers
l'autre
nous avons à résoudre des problèmes
difficiles nous devons les résoudre
ensemble nous devons le faire dans un
bon état d'esprit
en tout cas c'est ce que
je voudrais faire en tant qu' en tant
que président d'edf si les choses se
déroulent comme comme je le comme je le
souhaite pour je voudrais vraiment
rassuré sur ce plan-là je comprends mais
je rappelle que je ne suis pas encore
très au fait de tous les sujets dans
l'entreprise que des accords
enfin que pardon des travaux
préliminaires ont été faits ces derniers
mois qui permettent de bien expliquer de
biens est allé de même être sur la table
les sujets qui peuvent créer des
difficultés à la fois sur le plan de
l'ingénierie qui fait quoi pour définir
construire contrôler les produits et en
matière de commercialisation et je
voudrais mettre à profit les quelques
mois qui suivent avec areva pour aller
plus loin et si possible au résoudre de
façon définitive
cette cette relation en structurant sur
le plan de la coopération technique et
de la coopération commerciale en
structurant en établissant les choses de
façon claire et chacun sachant ce qu'il
a à faire
sans arrière pensée donc ce point me
paraît extrêmement importants sénateurs
beau grenard et d'autres ont parlé de le
p r du coup de la date de la livraison
de flamanville 3 nous ne pouvons les uns
et les autres qu'être désolé de voir un
grand projet sur notre territoire qui
implique grands acteurs que sont edf
areva et aussi d'autres d'autres
partenaires comme bouygues et alstom et
des dizaines et des centaines d'autres
ce grand projet dérivé sans qu'il soit
apparemment possible
de mettre totalement sous contrôle ni le
délai puisque il a été annoncé la
semaine dernière qu on parle maintenant
de 2017 non plus de fin 2016 ni
probablement les coûts parce qu il
m'étonnerait une fois potentiellement
arriver chez edf qu'un allongement des
délais permettent de tenir le devis je
ne sais pas ce qu'il en est mais je
serais surpris que j'ai des bonnes
nouvelles à vous annoncer
sur ce sujet là et donc il est clair que
ça doit être une priorité pour les
équipes industrielles à la fois du côté
d'areva et du côté d'edf et du côté des
éventuelles des autres partenaires qui
sont au coeur de ce chantier de faire en
sorte que nous puissions enfin respecter
les délais que nous ayons avec
l'autorité de sûreté qui bien sûr
derrière nous valide et prescrit les
exigences techniques les résultats
techniques que nous avons à réaliser
je crois qu'il est essentiel pour pour
nous je dirais presque pour l'honneur
national aussi que cette affaire soit
mise sous contrôle en tout cas ma
volonté sera demi attaché je n'en sais
pas beaucoup plus à ce stade mais dans
les prochaines semaines dans les
prochains mois il est clair que le
resserrement des liens avec areva et une
gestion plus contrôler toutes les
parties prenantes du projet du la
construction de flamanville 3 ces sujets
là sont absolument sont absolument
essentielles je voudrais parler de
certains sujets qui ont été abordés en
matière technologique autour des
énergies autour des énergies
renouvelables autour des technologies de
stockage des f&a des moyens de recherche
amont qui sont très significatifs
le centre de recherche qui va d'ailleurs
bientôt déménager à la fin de l'année
prochaine il sera sur le plateau de
saclay
au lieu de la du développement
scientifique et technologique en france
ces moyens sont importants
je crois que ces moyens doivent être mis
au service de l'entreprise dans le cadre
de ses intérêts stratégiques
c'est-à-dire des différentes filières
énergétiques l'entreprise développe et
de ce point de vue là vu les modes de
fonctionnement des énergies
renouvelables le solaire comme folle
folle comme l'éolien sont d énergie
intéressante mais intermittente et
l'intermittence créer des problèmes très
significatif l'intermittence crée des
problèmes significatifs en matière de
parc pour compléter l'intermittence que
se passe-t-il quand pendant la nuit
il n'y a pas de soleil que se passe-t-il
quand pendant les anticyclones il n'y a
pas de vent que se passe-t-il si on a
l'un et l'autre comment gérer comment
optimiser la gestion de ce parc peut y
avoir des questions sur l'évolution du
parc thermique l'optimisation de
l'hydroélectricité tous ces sujets là
sont sont difficiles et puis derrière à
moyen ou long terme le problème du
stockage qui peut être une réponse
le jour où ça fonctionnera à
l'intermittence deux principales
énergies renouvelables c'est un thème
qui doit être au coeur de la réflexion
stratégique d'edf et des moyens assez
importants je crois 5 ou 600 millions
d'euros qui sont mis sur la préparation
de cet avenir technologique important le
les sénateurs grémillet parler aussi
d'acceptabilité même dans le domaine des
énergies renouvelables le nucléaire mais
aussi les énergies renouvelables créent
des problèmes d'acceptabilité là je
crois que tous ensemble avec la
représentation nationale avec le
gouvernement avec les collectivités
locales de grâce et dont notre pays à
s'en sortir en rendant acceptables ces
investissements vont pas investir dans
rien c'est quand même quelque chose qui
poserait problème si nous n'avions pas
la capacité de répondre à ces questions
sociétales avec la volonté d'investir et
croyez bien que le président d'edf que
je pourrais être prochainement sera
extrêmement attentif à dépenser beaucoup
d'énergie à mettre beaucoup de moyens
pour rendre nos investissement
acceptable
cela peut faire partie aussi sénateur
montaugé en parler du projet social
collectif le projet social c'est le
corps social et l'acceptabilité à
l'intérieur du corps social des des
différentes dispositions qui sont prises
mais c'est aussi le retour par le corps
social d'edf vers la société vers les
impacts sociétaux des décisions qui sont
prises et faire en sorte que edf qui est
très présent dans les territoires qui
est prêtre est présent dans le monde
associatif et puisse jouer un rôle
majeur dans le débat pas simplement dans
le débat des colloques à paris mais
aussi dans le débat local qui est
important pour construire comme vous le
disiez notre projet collectif et je
notais monsieur le sénateur vous aviez
une une question sur le statut je
voudrais vous rassurer sur le fait que
autant le statut des ieg et jeu est une
exception dans le droit français autant
c'est la règle chez edf
voilà je voudrais peut-être terminée sur
les sujets qui sont liées à à des sujets
de territoire je ne sais pas si j'aurai
absolument traiter toutes les questions
qui étaient posées
je crois qu'il est important en effet
que le milieu rural reste très associée
au développement ou développement d'edf
vous m'avez alertés sur le fait que vous
prêt vous vous sentez le compteur linky
comme un sujet pour les urbains et j'en
suis un peu surpris mais je prends bonne
note du fait que ce projet n'est pas
considérée comme assez mûr pour être
déployés aussi rapidement en zone rurale
qu'il est en zone urbaine en tout cas je
me renseignerai sur ce que vous dites et
je ne vois aucune raison a priori pour
lequel le déploiement du compteur linky
se ferait dans l'ordre de densité de
population sur le territoire et je pense
de la même façon pour répondre aux
sénateurs ces arcs l'association des
élus par exemple en matière de de
préparation des relèves d'incidents et
de dérangement en matière de deux
tempêtes
l'association des élus les
correspondants tempête tout ce qui peut
développer davantage
la l'efficacité de ce qui est
malheureusement la réalité nous avons de
temps en temps et notamment sur la
façade ouest pas exclusivement mais
notamment ses façades ouest affaires à
faire face à des à des tempêtes et je
crois que c'est important d'y associer
les élus et peut-être aussi d'autres
acteurs locaux voilà je voudrais
terminer sur la dernière question les
dernières questions que me pose est le
président le noir en lui disant que
comme il peut s'y attendre je lui
répondrai que c'est à l'état de répondre
à la question de savoir sur la gestion
de son propre patrimoine tout cas
surveiller vos poches monsieur le
président merci monsieur le président
bien aimé goûter vous remercie pour cet
échange qui a été extrêmement
intéressant je remercie chaque sénateur
qui est intervenu et sénatrices bien sûr
pour la concision de l'intervention ce
qui a permis d'entendre un temps donc
tout à fait supportable par rapport à
d'autres engagements toutes les
personnes qui souhaitait intervenir
encore une fois un grand merci
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre
l'audition de jean bernard lévy devant
la commission des affaires économiques
du sénat jean marc levy qui devrait
remplacer henri proglio à la tête d'edf
tout de suite ses preuves par 3 avec
michel grossiord et perrine tarneaud